let me walk you through it like i said
the working is very simple
but it's about getting over that
conceptual hump of do i understand what
this is all talking about okay
so oh sorry let's turn this up read the
question with me
and i've got to introduce a couple of
terms and explain why they're
significant
okay so a particle of mass 3 kilograms
first piece of information
it moves with uniform circular motion so
that gives us a lot of assumptions
about the forces and accelerations and
velocity that's behaving here
okay it's on a smooth table
that word's important you'll see that
come up a lot it's it's moving
what that means is we don't have to
worry about friction
that's basically all that means smooth
table speed of four
meters per second okay
and it's attached to a fixed point on
the table by a light
inelastic string okay so it's light
it's light meaning that the um
the weight of the string right the
weight of the string
if it's heavy enough if i have like a
super super heavy string
it's going to influence the forces at
play right so when they say
light that means you don't have to worry
about the string and
its mass it's not really going to play
into this situation you can disregard it
uh it's inelastic sorry so i said light
that means forget about the weight of
the string right inelastic you can tell
me what that means
what does that mean it doesn't get
longer doesn't get
shorter okay so in other words you're
going to have a constant radius and that
constant radius is
2 meters okay
great find the tension in the string now
just like with like with the beginning
questions under mechanics right
f equals m a was where you started for
like
95 of the questions okay so for uniform
circular mission
take that back for circular motion full
stop
right what makes it circular what keeps
it in a circle
is these equations right if the force
was any less the particle would spiral
off it would sort of have this like an
elliptic or something like that
if the force was any greater it would
spiral in and it would collide with the
odor and it wouldn't be circular anymore
okay so you can start with this so
here's my starting point
okay now like we mentioned before
tension is really just this
this force right um we're not really
going to worry about the um the
direction of it because it's kind of
implied okay obviously it's going
inwards otherwise
it's going to fling off to wherever okay
now t
is a sort of capital t um because it's
pretty obvious that we don't care about
the temperature of the objects in this
context
t is fine for tension okay and in the
same way because i don't worry about the
um
the direction of this is kind of implied
i'm just working out this
really okay now think back
you have to be careful with i mean this
is kind of death by algebra right you
have to be careful about what all of
your
pronouns are omega omega how do we
define omega
it's angular velocity right now in this
constant
context because it's uniform right we
can think back to the fact that
well omega right
it's related to linear velocity
in what way how are they related
oops that linear velocity there linear
maybe you can see why they have another
term for this right
it really is tangential velocity it's
going around in this curve
okay and that's why it's an arc right
and so what you've got
is you've got your theta there right and
that's changing at a rate of
omega and then you've got your radius
okay
so the change in your arc length right
that velocity
is r omega does that make sense okay
so what you've got here instead of omega
i don't want this in terms of
omegas right i just want to work out the
tension and i've got this this velocity
instead right
so instead of an angular velocity i'm
going to sub it out for a linear
velocity
the way that i do that is you come down
to here and you say well
if i've got omegas but i want to get rid
of them
i'll make it a subject here so this
should be v on
r is that okay right so when you come
here this is gonna be m r v
on r squared is that okay
so in fact this line's really important
um
you can really write this original force
if you want to put the minus sign on it
right in this case it's just a tension
but you can use this another color as
your starting point
you can use this as your starting point
if you don't have things in terms of an
angular
velocity right if you don't have
revolutions per minute
but if you have something like this then
why would you have a mate why would you
have omegas in this starting point right
you're gonna have to get rid of them so
that's an
equally valid starting point right so
from there
once you've gotten to this point you can
just punch in your numbers right
what's the mass what do we say three
kilos right
velocity is 4 so v squared will be 16
and then there's our radius 2 right
so 3 by 16 is 48 divided by 2 that gives
you
24 newtons that's the tension in the
string
that's the force acting toward the
center
okay so far so good when we have a look
at part b what's it asking
if the string has a tensile strength of
15 kilograms okay mark those words with
me
tensile strength we'll come back to
these in a second
15 kilograms find the
greatest angular velocity that the mass
can have
without the string breaking okay
so what you've got here this tensile
strength 15 kilograms right
what it's telling you is now now it's
forgetting about this speed right
because the question is now
what speed can i have right so we're
forgetting about this four
that means you can forget about this 24
okay
this is what i'm going to have for my
tension right but because it's 15
kilograms right you think kilograms
really
the tension is 15 times gravity
right now 9.8 is pretty standard
10 comes up a lot i don't actually know
i'm just going to leave it as g for now
and we can sub in whatever value that
they say
take gravity be equal to 10 meters per
second or whatever okay
so 15 now what am i looking for what's
the question say
i want greatest angular velocity yes so
think do i want to go with this or do i
want to go with this
angular velocity right i want omega in
there so i'm just going to say well
that's
m r omega squared that's all i had to do
right that's the tension i want so at
least that's the maximum
right and then i'm just gonna solve i
know what mass and radius are
right 15 g
okay so now i just have to solve for
omega
15 g on six what's that
five five g on two
we're not really worrying about the um
the thing changing
angular direction right it's just gonna
keep going forward so therefore i can
just take the positive
the square root of five g on
two for positive omega
okay so obviously if you took um if you
took g is
10 you'd have the square root of 25 or
the square root of
24.5 if you use the other value of
gravity
okay so that's all there is to it like i
said
um just like f equals m is your starting
point for so many mechanics questions in
general
this is the specific kind of m equals m
a either of these um that you get with
circular motion
so that's why it's your starting point
as soon as you see that
you're like bam that's where i'm gonna
go okay